in the Alabama Cooperative Extension
system we are in the business of helping
people the animal waste and nutrient
management team can help producers
effectively use the mineral and
nutrients within it Alabama Cooperative
Extension is my number one go-to and
resource from our farming operation our
team consists of extension specialists
regional agents and agency partners who
want to help producers use animal waste
in a way which is beneficial both to
their farms and the environment our
mission is truly to talk about
environmental stewardship and what
nutrient management should be how
nutrient management is a part of
environmental stewardship we have a lot
of soils in this state that are degraded
Souls we've got to figure out those ways
that we can be more productive and one
of the best ways to do that is to
increase soil health and we can do that
through wise use of animal manures soil
and Mineo testing has great benefits it
is important to know not only what you
have eaten your soles but also what you
are applying to them really common
testing on a regular basis by sending
samples to a small testing lab like the
one here at Auburn University soil
testing grip sample is one of the best
things you can do you need to know
what's going on in your soul and what
your needs are we can give you
information on efficient use of manure
such as when and how much to apply I
definitely would say here and on any
cropland acres we certainly don't over
ply we try to apply enough to get what
we need to get as far as yields and and
get to the pasture where we need to get
it and by using soil tests to try to see
if we should or shouldn't apply
overflying fertilizer it's not throwing
money away but it's not helping the
environment you really have to pay
attention to your nutrient management
there's much to be lost from
over-application as there is under
application you have to do it wisely
we can't start not what we know is being
sound environmental stewardship
practices and so we can do that we're
not here selling anything we have
nothing but pre advice to give and so
that's what we're all about is helping
growers to help themselves and to help
the land also there's time certainly
that I've called our Regional Extension
agent up those are great resources to to
help us it helps clear the mind up and
answer the question so we've got to
produce much more with less we're all
working together towards the same goal
and we'll get the job done but it's a
partnership in between the farmer and
extension it's going to help us to get
there call or email us and we will help
you find the answers you need for more
information check out our website or our
Facebook page
[Music]